all right so man we got a typical boring
episode called King worm and no I like
this no I
I love surrealistic stuff and I love
dream stuff and this whole episode was
pretty much a dream but I like when they
can tie it into depending on what
they're trying to do if it's like a
David Lynch thing it's like okay just
let it be a dream whatever but if it's a
show I'm like yeah if you can tie in the
story sort of that's fine but still keep
the spirit of a dream and that's pretty
much what they do Finn is obviously in a
dream and Jake seems to be in the dream
as well and he's telling them that they
had to get this worm why no I seen
before and he's teasing me he's gonna
tell me a minute but I know I see him
before and I don't remember but I
remember seeing a man that he's somehow
controlling this dream and they had to
get him in order to stop the dream and
it's just them churning through trying
to figure stuff out eventually at the
end fitness to key opens up his fears
like his biggest fears and that totally
scares away the worm or at least takes
away his energy because that's what he
wanted he wanted Finn's energy and
finally the dream is broken and King
worm is really decrepit and falling
apart stuff and he's good worm and he
leaves yeah which was I love that and
this is what's so great about a kid's
voice changes and say you can make that
weird sound like no sounds great that's
really funny
so yeah I really liked it i I thought it
was extremely creative I like sort of
the different styles of animation they
do sometimes it couldn't make me even
used a bit more like I really like let
me go the father and they sort of do
that different neon background with the
regular animation
I like the confronting the fears I like
him like if one fears enough he has to
go to another one he has to keep
confronting and I like that you know
again shows how you know he's supreme
he'll go through this stuff you know
he'll face it and
yeah just very sort of eternal sunshine
ish mixed with inception ish and I'm
really inception um that what's the one
thing I've missed in Inception it's like
yeah it's so dreamlike except for what
you usually see in dreams like this is
what I see injuries but I know that was
the idea I'm gonna attract I really like
that about you I just want to see your
dreams know my truth I never know it's a
dream that's our every time I know it's
a dream I wake up so I can never control
it I'm always really jealous of people I
can control it I know there's a few
things you can do I know like what he
looks in the mirror I know that's
something they say is like really tough
to do like you can't look in the mirror
really never reflect about ya next time
your dreams see if you can find you a
reflection of water or a mirror or
something it won't look normal like
that's one of the dead giveaways um
if for those that watch them in the
animated series there's this thing where
if you tried to read in a book they say
the show that you can't but I think
depending you can a little bit but it's
still difficult you know like you can
serve read a sentence but you can't you
can read a sentence maybe two but then
they'll Sartre go tell me one dreaming
all the time
maybe that feeling reading anyway so
maybe a part of my dream
no God a part of yours oh okay yes so
what do you think know one thing I loved
I loved this episode but I do like the
bizarre in this range and all that of
course but for me it is there is a ton
of references to past episodes and there
are some nods to things to come okay
which i think is even again it's one of
those things where okay the King worm
you remember
hug me hug me they come home and before
the whole time fins like no worms on the
bed then they come home and there's the
giant King worm going and they get
hypnotized he's like hug me hug me okay
and is that where the episode yeah
so it's man you could almost say like
the past whatever a couple dozen episode
for a dream that almost couldn't you
potentially that if you really piss off
a lot of there's also the fear Feaster
the oh it the well that's the guy who
came out of the belly button right he's
the one that has the box with the key oh
that's right okay yeah well once again
was of the the I always we get the
stitch or the Lich I always forget
so I you can you can mouth shut he was
saying like you're gonna see some during
this episode aren't you aren't you the
Lich peoples with the age all the stuffs
come up in the past one of my favorites
though what's the girl
um not Flame Princess
no the ghostly girl that comes up oh
yeah he's letting out all of his fears
yeah and then the sort of ghost girl
comes out last night ghost princess
right yeah remember where that's from
the ghost girl ah apparently jewelry
does she's going you can talk
the house on Haunted Hill episode the
masquerade one where he's like oh I
forgot to I all those Foucault sounds
actually legitimately haunting them and
he goes I'm gonna put that one in the
vault and it's gone okay that's
hilarious that is really funny cuz you
have to you have to like really remember
that joke yeah it's just a fight I love
how the show can do that could just take
sort of funny little throwaway joke I
can legitimately come back well what I
love for me is that when they bring up
the fierce they bring up legitimate
fears that he has dealt with throughout
the show and not just like okay the
scary creatures or his fear of the ocean
which I love cuz when he first comes to
it looks like he's peeing it yeah I
thought you know I use afraid wetting
the batters that he stands up and it's
the waters like the ocean okay that huge
pier he had to deal with and it's going
through and then there's the people pop
people's pops out and remember Jordans
like people what I'm not good at about
the age my love just like okay see I'm
having coffee with the Lich
yeah I'm having tea with Liz I just like
the sets it's only from all this creepy
stuff - like an almost pleasant yeah
having tea and everything and then just
okay CR - yeah I love that they're
actually dealing with things that he's
always dealt with throughout the show
well what I like - which is interesting
is that you know that one episode he
says you know before I think it's before
we were questioning that but you know it
just said no I'm done with you I put
behind me it seemed like he's over it
but there's a part that's never truly
gonna leave you know once that scar hich
it's like even if you're moving on it so
it still gonna be a scar it's never
gonna leave so no I like that too
because I first I don't know how to feel
about that I'm like are they kind of
opening this up again or whatever but
it's like it's it's a scar I mean that
that's something that would stay well I
see for me one thing that always drives
me nuts when TV shows do it is that they
have supernatural shows that is is where
they have you or the main characters
fighting off their deepest fears
whatever their deepest fears may be and
most of time it's you just like spiders
or clowns and this is the other thing
and then these shows they always show
that it's incredibly easy this happens
your eyes and going yeah you have to
battle it for a second and loop it's
gone and that always bothers me it's
like no if it's a true deepest fear you
just can't battle it that fast for the
most part and this is kind of one of
those things were Finn when he battled
the whole water the ocean before you saw
he conked himself out he wasn't done and
over with it but he we've never gone
back to it the Lich we've never gone
really back to in a sense but this shows
that he still has those fears there just
cuz he conquered those beasts are those
beings doesn't mean he's still not
terrified of what was going on well I
think the same thing here too is that he
he opens all these uppity keeps adding
them on top of each other to get rid of
this thing to break out and they're
still it's not like they even after now
they've left him they're still gonna be
inside there it's no gonna be these
legit fears you have these conquered
them in real life
yo you know it's just because someone
can like whatever
conquered this big bad monster
me later you're not still gonna be
afraid of that monster and you don't
want to do it again that and that's my
issue with a lot of older shows and I
really love how they do that in here
and then of course I love at the end
where he's like I'm a clown that's it I
really love this one especially just a
lot of the animation a lot of what I we
now have big legs and Jake's like what
wait a minute I can always do this we
have birds then you have a bird yeah no
I like that
uh-uh LSPs raining from the sky yeah
that was funny um and the you know I
thought one episode because I was afraid
was gonna be like this episode glad it
wasn't there it's a strange episode
compared to but there's never saw The
Sopranos where it did gon do it well but
they go to one or two dreams like
whatever for a minute and they wakes up
but there's one episode where either
half of it or like 70% of it was just
this dream and it didn't connect to
anything or if you read into it it might
connect to something but for the
majority of the episode it's this dream
and that's it and it really pissed me
off that there's a lot of people off and
it's because it didn't match the rest of
the show and it's okay if you do
something different but stuff to be in
the spirit of the show and I really
thought what this did is that every
episode still even if a lot of crazy
stuff is going on it still has a story
it still has a focus or an agenda or a
quest or something going on it follows
its own rules yeah and and this one
still does that if they said dream but
well why would we want to be with them
in a dream for so unless we find out
something or there's some suspense and
we kind of do both I mean we do find out
a little bit more about them and there's
also this you know suspense on Willy get
out how is he gonna get out and stuff so
I like that I thought it was a good
balance and and funny - it was creative
it was funny see also for me it's that
there's a legitimate reason why this is
going on
he's not just sleeping and the strange
thing is going on no this is being done
to him yeah and I like the I get is sort
of like Wonderland figuring out what are
the rule
ways and how do I work with and you know
what do I have to unlearn and what do I
have to relearn and I like this or is
this person lying is this person even
the person I think they are and I I
really like that where you have to
really kind of use your wit to figure it
out you know you have to think a little
mad as well to think like all the mad
people do yeah so so no I didn't I liked
it I liked I liked serve the deductive
reasoning in a sense world too and no I
didn't I know I was gonna that was a
really cool episode I really like the
fact that they didn't even try to hide
the fact that it was a dream kind of
from the get-go you knew something
strange was going on by his extended
length that was one giveaway one they
think they're out of the dream like now
they're still in the dream they're still
well they don't even try to hide it
which I really enjoy there's the one
Family Guy episode where Stewie kills
Lois and it's a two-parter and at the
end of the two-parter it's been just a
simulation the whole time yeah I think
most people know this but what I love is
that Brian brings up the fact of all
these shows that do a dream sequence
where the whole episode has been
completely stupid and pointless there
was no reasoning behind it and you know
he's like but wouldn't that make people
mad oh but people should enjoy the ride
but isn't it like giving a giant middle
finger to everyone watching that's kind
of how I feel most of the time but with
this one you knew kind of from the
get-go that something strange was up and
you're right you actually learned
something about him about a lot of
things well I think the same thing with
this and like the feeling cake is
setting up from the beginning look this
is not gonna be like the normal go we're
not gonna trick you we're going to do
something that you know from the
beginning is different yeah you can't
really enjoy the rock and so you can
really enjoy it you can enjoy that
you're watching something different not
feeling like you got the suckered over
something that's not really even that
good of a twist you just weren't told
yes like when Dallas did it with the
whole who shut jr. and everything
okay that was amazing for its time when
Bob Newhart's oh yeah but with some
extent
the Newhart show was GZ that was great
when he wakes up in the last the show
that everyone had just been watching had
all been a dream or elsewhere yeah
seen elsewhere where the whole thing's
been in this mind of a autistic child
yeah okay like those types of things
works like haha that's a pretty good
twist which you'd never seen up until
that point in time but now like it's
done all the goddamn time and it's kind
of like lame yeah and I don't know
there's still there's a way to do the
Dallas well by the way I hear a lot of
people get pissed off that by the way I
hear that's one that's like even for the
time it's like no that's sucked I don't
like that I was a kid and I remember
when jr. got shot I don't know I I
watched Dallas with my parents and I
barely remember most of it but I
remember - Erik getting shot everyone
all like up in arms like oh my god jr.
Jer are there like I don't remember how
long it was later else and it's like oh
that never happened I was like oh so you
know now looking back it's like they
tried to totally retcon it
yeah well that's exact my people to get
I mean it was just like a last minute no
no this didn't happen cuz we found out
these characters really popular and
stuff but but some like saying elsewhere
like and maybe that's it it seems like
it fits yo yeah with the I think you
said it follows the show's own roles
with the Bob Newhart show and the way
that's an end with Newhart that they set
up their own rules and he felt like no
no this could end this way it's not the
same thing was saying elsewhere because
it was a little strange and yes a little
odd that the woods are this sense of no
I can see that like it shook I've been
this way it should be a little off it
should be a little weird yeah so yeah I
think you nailed it it has to follow its
own rules and I think this does as
strange and bizarre as it is it does set
these very smart rules that make us want
to keep coming back and learning more
and finding out more and constantly
surprise so yeah no I know